l'été c'est aussi l'occasion de voir ou
de revoir des films la commanderie à
elancourt se transforme en salle de
cinéma
chaque jeudi de l'été des fines ils sont
projetés on jette un coup d'oeil
est ce que vous croyez c'est comme ça
vous allez gagner ce juste participer de
rigoler vous avez tous les tanks et on
va aller courir d une palombe dégagé
minutes d'arrêt
tout cela semble avoir été répété tout
le monde commet l éthique là que votre
embrouilles en fait tu la laisses aller
au bout de son délire avant minuit
j'oublie tout bas
azur et asmar l'histoire de deux enfants
devenu prince dans un conte des mille et
une nuits
[Musique]
vous dites que vous avez fabriqué une
machine à voyager dans le temps à partir
d'une de l'oréal il fait faire un marty
un bond de 30 ans dans le passé sans
morale